is morality different is morality
different for different people like if I
steal and you steal it's been a general
night but I think some people will kind
of rationalize what they're doing and
then say that they have their reasons
for it and then I'm not I don't know
their lives so I don't know what their
reasons would be but if I steal it
because I'm hungry does that does that
make it different it's not okay but
people are gonna do what they're gonna
do so if they do it no but I'm asking if
you think it's moral no I've not for me
I wouldn't no but for everyone do you
think it's moral no no no no okay okay
thank you all right go ahead hell no and
I and I think like now
um you know I also think as I get older
like if I had a daughter what would my
answer be right like I think it's you
know just think about that but also too
like I think the word the terminology
sex work is it's it's a really like
large term there's a lot of things that
could be encompassed within that but I
also think uh sex work you know could be
you know a lot of these Hollywood stars
that you know show up half naked to the
red carpet right like I was looking at
the Oscars and and Sierra just showed up
to the Oscars uh like literally half
naked and she has two or three kids and
is married to a a a multi
multi-millionaire Russell Wilson that to
me is a component of sex work as well
because she's taking degrees of her
sexuality putting it somewhere and and
going to get brand deals because of it
right like and everything that comes
from it right so like I even think when
we talk about sex work the definition
has to be expanded for modern times
today because although she's not doing
that and getting direct money or maybe
that she is from the outfit that she's
wearing she could be right but then also
what comes of that right and if there's
an exchange of money then that's sex
work as well
uh I don't know me I don't know my my
thought was on the different everybody
else I don't I don't really see nothing
wrong with it
because like
since we're been going on since the
beginning of time it's never gonna stop
have you ever had a problem no I don't I
don't I don't buy I don't do that but
I'm just saying it's gonna happen like
women gonna get money they're gonna use
what they got to get money me ain't
gonna do the same thing see I'm like
torn on it because on one hand
I sometimes agree with you like I
sometimes think it's needed in a society
because
what are the one in three men gonna do
and if you if you think sex is a need
which it sort of is for men
but then it just makes my stomach turn
to say that too
[Music]
let me ask you let me ask you something
who you think has six more
a regular girl
or somebody who do only fans like who
got one person one person who they sleep
with the only fan they do only thing who
you think regular girl I would agree who
you think having sex mode or a stripper
versus something for just a regular girl
no I think it's the I think girls that
do promiscuous Behavior are like tend to
make more promiscuous like choices like
I think if someone does that they're
probably more likely to sleep around
that's my opinion I know some people
will say no but I would be able to do I
I'm I would really be able to do okay
I'm with you I don't know why I'm always
with you but I'm with you
um
we've been close with this triple or
kind of see what they what they do like
they schedule how they work
damn really yeah they they going to the
club doing anything they come home count
up their money get up in the morning go
to the bank deposit them once they ain't
really out here just messing around like
that but it might be another girl who
going to the strip club
just throwing ones on them but they
[__] that night yeah girls in the
strip club are desensitized to it right
so that they're when you are
stripping for a man and doing that you
have to sell a fantasy to him right you
have to get into this Persona and give
him the dream for the night so he will
give you the money right and so once you
come off of that in your home and you're
with your family or whatever you usually
they have kids that they're taking care
of and they're doing so for they're
exhausted they're tired because I just
had to go and pretend to be someone that
I wasn't and I don't even want I'm I'm
disgusted by men to a certain degree
right because I know how creepy they are
they come here and they're their most
vulnerable and nasty and all the stuff
that everyone else is going to look at
you crazy for I have to take it because
you're paying me to take it so I think
they're desensitized to it honestly I
can see your point and then on the other
end
um it's a girl I'm not going to say her
name but she's super big only fan like
she she getting like 200 000 a month on
the fan she only she only sleep with one
dude on only fans yeah there's girls
like that as well think about it she
getting money you can't you can't you
don't get more money to her and she
already got a dude who who pleases her
sexually so she not you're not gonna
even go be able to go mess with yeah but
but the question is based on morality
morality is count is grounded in
principles so then but what would you be
okay but what is morality what are the
things that we do on every on every day
for for the for money but let's say that
you had a daughter as a father you pass
on virtues you you pass on values you
pass on principles you pass on morality
if your daughter is doing that is that
something yeah I'm not gonna agree with
my daughter doing it so then the answer
to the question for you is no I'm not
I'm not gonna I wouldn't agree with my
my daughter or my senior doing a lot of
[__] I do but I'm grown yeah imma do it
tomorrow okay
babies in the right way and Hope
and hope they grow up and do the things
that you'll be pleased with yeah
I think there's a place for them I think
it's been there for a long time I think
that if you're going to be a sex worker
you should be single you shouldn't
expect no man and there should be a [__]
Island
Island and you know like was it called
Hit The Box thing
so like can regular people go to the
island like I think that's something
we should do a reality show for me I
think it becomes tomorrow when they
they're looking for they've got children
they've got Partners or they expect to
get a man through it and I think that if
you're going to be a sex worker
that's what you're going to be
nothing else and expect to be a wife you
shouldn't be a mom I think if you're a
mother and you're you're a sex worker
you're the only fans I think if you're a
partner and you're the only fan or
anything like that I think of your wife
no but other than that if you're single
you want to go and do it and you're
harming no one go to slow Island
not everyone as women know I do think
now I will say this and it ain't my
place to say this either but I do think
it's a time limit on it
at a certain point so you old is here
you need to get your at the streets but
nobody's gonna want you after that
that's what I'm saying stay on the
island because once you've started
there's women out there it depends it
depends how bad that she is have you
seen that there's an article about like
an 80 year old woman on Tinder guys were
still yeah
she'll be like the five dollar special a
scent will always forgive if she bad
enough yeah
um I'm curious what do you guys think is
sex work moral immoral um
uh I don't know I I personally think
like I have a lot of friends and a lot
of people so maybe I'm a bit
desensitized to it but I think corn has
been happening for ages I think as
consent in adults you know well corn has
it yeah it's been okay how before
even before like think about it we had
sex with statues even of naked women
like women have always been kind of
admired for their bodies the statues are
the same thing as like not really but I
mean as in like admiring women for their
bodies and like I don't know I just we
don't think there's a difference between
like a sexual picture and like a beaut
because some of the olders
pictures the other side
um wouldn't it be the same difference
though
whose phone's ringing
um some but some of the older pictures
it's it's because time to move forward
though so I can imagine even sex back
then wasn't how we have sex now you know
we've become more and more uh modern
freaky disgusting
disgusting you know people what people I
think watch corn really early and normal
sex becomes boring and you want to spice
things up and you do more and more
things that maybe didn't happen back in
the day not say that that's right or
wrong it's for everything yeah well yeah
yeah
so to answer the question moral or
immoral I don't think it's a moral no I
just I think it's moral
so then you think it's immoral I I don't
know each to their own I think it's each
to their own I think if moral or immoral
we gotta
I think if you're single and like you
said Andy said it was moral yeah I think
it is moral as long as it suits your
lifestyle and like she said I think as
long as you don't expect to for everyone
just to accept it and understand I think
is moral and I said Don't expect a man
don't expect anyone to marry you I think
women too they actually make sure you're
talking in here so you shouldn't have
any children don't expect a man once you
decide on the sex work that's you too
you die do you get sex work insurance no
I'm not saying that I think I'm saying
that's how it should be because if
somebody knows that this is how you
start you're not you're gonna you're not
gonna get anybody that should be able to
put women off but there's women are
going out there saying I can go and be
only friends and I can still get a
husband I can then we're gonna be only
fans I'm not going to have my children I
can be only fans no after you know that
that is it you're gonna have to take
dick for the rest of your life
you get the scraps women that go out and
don't do only you don't get high value
around a lot anyone that has sex for
money anybody that ever anything about
money I'm talking about like just normal
people that when they don't have their
children they go out and they sleep with
loads of people and they don't do only
fans but they still get married and they
still get respected
because we've got I'm not weave because
there's a platform that you're like
showcased on it's highlighted but
there's a lot of women in privacy that
do a lot worse
do you know what it says if you go on
only fans that you have no shame
even
you think kids don't mind I mean kids
don't obviously kids don't have like the
same view I mean like mums and dads like
some people just you know and that's but
it's still saying I'm putting my my
money before bringing shame to the
family name
depending on what your family view is on
it right but I'm saying what are the
kids get no say in this so it still it
still goes back to I always talk about
this the me me culture where it's been
before the children yeah oh okay well
hopefully the kids will turn out fine
but you know I need this money so I'm
gonna do this now there's a lot of porn
stars with children that are okay as
well sorry sorry yeah
um outliers some people literally listen
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible